ich habe noch nie eine freundin oder
meinen ja ich habe angst
[Musik]
willkommen war nur ein video
heute ihr seht schon ich habe ein den
kennt ja mittlerweile christian erzeugt
wie david hayter freut mich sehr da
drehte man zu sagen ja nur videos und
wir haben uns hingesetzt heinz glas ey
was können wir machen und vor eigentlich
so genau einem jahr ich glaube am 16.5
2016 eben irgendwo mit einer der ersten
- von uns beiden zusammen
[Musik]
auf jeden fall war es ein
ich hab noch nie das haben wir da auch
gebracht das lebensfeuer ich denke das
spiel oder die challandes sollte euch
ein was sagen wir haben es ganz einfach
mal gedacht acom machen man zweiten part
wollen wir da weitermachen wo auf jeden
fall wichtig ist auch cool durch
angekommen ganz gut für die dies mit
verstehen und war hat der christian fünf
fragen rausgesucht über sich und ich hab
den frage warum ich rausgesucht die
eigene person begründet und also müsst
euch jetzt darauf einschlichen das ist
anders als das trinkspiel ich hab noch
nicht wir brauchen hier keine faxen sie
haben noch gar keine kerzen
wir brauchen noch kurz kehrt erwartet
wir machen gerade die kärtchen so leute
passt auch gerne einmal einen park und
stiftung woche ja alex ihm hatten mehr
steht natürlich für jahr und das kreuz
zu sein und prinzip ist ganz einfach
christian vergleich zum beispiel bei
sich ich hatte noch nie sex und dann
kann ich direkt hammer sagen ja das
stimmt ricky van überstanden
anfang bis zur schnickschnack schlug
deswegen jetzt überhaupt anfängt dass
ein mann das wird echt land der intimes
video gab es schon lange nicht mehr
ich hab noch nie vor der polizei
flüchten
das ist ja langweilig musste ein sanfter
reichen muss die juden bitte mal vor der
polizei flüchten
nein was er nicht weiß ganz genau stimmt
ich bin ein engelchen flieg habe ich
erstmal die einfache genau ich habe noch
nie bei den eltern die frage beantworten
müssen ob ich noch jungfrau bin ich
kenne deine eltern
ich würde sagen ich mich gefragt was
denn in gefahr
und du musst es antworten der nächsten
kreuzung zu dumm was halt nicht noch mal
vor ich habe noch niemanden eltern die
frage beantworten müssen ob ich noch
jung vorbild
das gilt für nein ich bin dass du
komisch immer ich muss jetzt ja sagen ja
wenn ich das schon mal gemacht hat musst
du ja sagen ich hab noch nie
das und das gemacht und dann weißt du
doch hast du schon aber jetzt bin ich
der glaube ach so erläutert leute
herzlich für doch hast hast du nicht so
genau also doch hab ich schon
die hat doch du musst die frage
beantworten warum ich hab noch nie nackt
im meer oder ein see gebadet besser kann
er bestimmt so gut erzählen sowieso
keine ahnung im urlaub fahrt oder war
das müsse schon war das mal schon zu
einem urlaub der extraklasse die man
denkt so einbinden wird ich habe noch
nie ein spiel gespielt bei dem man sich
ausziehen musste allerdings hat generell
große probleme vor 490 auszuziehen und
deswegen sage ich hatte noch nicht
gemacht
hedge-fonds laxey jetzt weite mal wie
das ist wenn man nur übernahmen scheitel
aber doch hab ich auch schon immer
gewinnen
kein detail ich nehme mal an anders als
alle habe ich noch nie einem einer
führerscheinprüfung theorie oder praxis
wieder ohne müssen halt nicht weiß wer
nicht auto fahren kann ich muss das aber
auch nicht machen
[Musik]
ich bin also ich habe noch nie mit
jemandem schlafe ich erstmal ein paar
stunden kannte ich ja noch nie davon
geträumt eine mitschülerin nackt zu
sehen die ein oder andere würde ich mal
sagen ich denke hätten was normal ist
könnt ihr jetzt ihren vornamen nennen so
das nicht ist mir so ich bin noch nie
drei abende hintereinander besoffen
gewesen bist du hundertprozentig gewesen
denn was mein vater urlaub gehabt wie
der alt genug und wissen wie man mit
alkohol um kinder die leute uns kennt
wirklich voll eine grand das sind echt
ich habe es jetzt mal von alke trotz der
recht sind oder so er ist einfach so
erläuterte dass auf jeden fall wichtig
und sollten mit auf den weg geben
alkohol auf paik und was tut das dürfen
auf keinen fall ein positives angesehen
das ist immer noch eine droge meine
freunde und jetzt bin ich dran und als
nächstes kommt ich hab noch nie meine
freundin oder meinen wäre ich hab keinen
freund findet man überall freundin
betrogen für deine freundin nicht aber
sein freund also nicht machst du bist du
mich noch nicht ran gegangen bin ich
auch hier das nicht aber was du
geleistet werden schließt jetzt
vielleicht auf das gegenteil
du hast auch vollauf nein habe ich nicht
nein hast überhaupt er jahre oder älter
hat die ganze zeit nur scheiße habt ihr
das nicht verstanden guck mal das ist
doch nur einfach ne das ist für hast du
doch gemacht in das gefühl hast du nicht
gemacht
das andere erst mal ich hab noch nie
miteinander spielt das wir allen wir
können ja aber schlecht dabei saufen
oder es ist ja an sich ein trinkspiel
aber nein ich spiele einfach so für
youtube bei youtube viel besser zeit
irgendwelche trinkspiele hab ich schon
gesagt hätte dass ich ein video zeigt
auf jeden fall christian stuff check bei
mir ist napster und wir sind auch die
weite sachen absolut genau bereit meinen
klamotten stopp auch mal eben in der
videos verlinkt gehabt die neue
kollektion ist jetzt online kann einmal
vorbeischauen
bei soltau gekommen es nichts video mit
christian und wir sind uns sonntag
wieder sonntag kommt ein verdammt weil
die videos seien
[Musik]